listen we all have a lot of stress all
right i i didn't eat
my dad was dealing with something you
wouldn't shut
up oh my god oh yeah
it's in the back oh you got it yeah what
happened
uh my dad like again i was we had to pay
like twelve hundred dollars
to get it out to get it out yeah and so
you got it out got it we selling this
thing yeah let's sell it
yeah let's sell it i'm gonna have brian
johnson or marty create a graphic and
we're gonna
find a kid to sell okay you got to see
when he first got it go to my story
channel
you went with her yeah you had to take
him to it
on sunday uh yeah damn you're a good
friend man
yeah look at the water she's back she
looked back man watch who watch a rabbit
look at that look at that engine and we
running watch it
get up it's gonna get up wait just like
this dude
go look what that person said she looks
like
she doesn't sound like she had cody with
that ring
oh you posted picture you and him
getting oh yeah i got sheila oh yeah i
posted yeah recent picture
so we selling sheila or what yeah
yeah that's like look at look at that
he's doing that thing i'm selling big
mama um
uh i got an offer this weekend uh five
thousand dollars was the highest
i'll sell it huh sell it no sell it yeah
but five thousand great offer
sell that though no but again i think it
worth five grand i know it's worth seven
so i'm thinking i'm thinking like yo if
you can beat that or just come close to
seven grand
get it off your hands hey so you're
you're maybe you only stop for seven or
or more uh seven close it has to be
close to seven now have you talked about
6500
i got that what about what about 5800
yeah i'm sorry
hell yeah yeah see you because you're
not a regular person i'm not
yo she knows what i'm saying bro that's
the best value that's value right that's
really boring
you get that you get that sumbitch
detail you get that radio fix
or you can or you could add the
bluetooth speaker with it listen okay
what i'm saying ooh but buy him a new
yeah get a new bluetooth
or sign the hood i signed a hood signup
if someone did come and say hey why are
you missing a lug nut
on the bottom
sell it for five thousand so you drove
chappelle to work today
nah should we drove separately because i
got xbox after this
but yeah i'm selling it for we're gonna
sell this thing and get what
we're gonna get uh yeah man we still we
i we still haven't like solidified that
no no
all right two things two choices we're
getting the bmw m4
i'm leaning that towards jay because jay
was like that but they also fans was
like yo bmw
m2 competition well that's the best one
what's the m2
no i wouldn't go with the m2 i go i'd go
with the m4 personally
you don't you have an m2 no i have a
430i
430 yeah i love that m2 competition 52.
yeah we're gonna have to get this bad
[ __ ] used to get it used okay
[ __ ] yeah yeah that that'd be frosty oh
[ __ ]
yeah rolly look at that one that's hard
that is hard hell yeah okay so yeah just
like i'll let the fans decide man we'll
get the m2 or the uh
m4 oh yes put uh
m4 is that front yeah
how much is the m4 yeah how much you use
them for chin
use now because we're gonna have five
ground to put down yeah
so that means you're gonna finance
around 50 something okay
and plus i'm uh my credit is great well
yeah you're good
is what year though i'd go 2016 might be
cheaper
because they all they changed the body
style a little bit so they depreciated
i feel like they depreciate a little bit
so you might be able to get oh yeah and
then
yeah and m4 for mac a little cheaper
cheaper okay
so you said 2016. oh let's dude let's
get the titties out and go drop top you
want the drops oh damn that 2 on 17
44 so that means you financed 39 daddy
i'm with that
and look at that yeah but that's in west
palm beach that's what the la prices
uh chin it'll probably be the same this
one well there's a white one in monbella
for 47.
oh okay that means we're fine okay do
you want white
well i want red interior i want red and
white and red do you want that cat what
the cat has that
yeah they're redding too give me that
cat or black and red but i'm looking for
towards rubbing
oh hold on go up chin there's one in
ontario black with red leather
51 okay it's a little higher where where
where where
do you want it right there dog it could
be you oh the inside chin
is that red or brown i have to see
anything inside this definitely red
there we go yes sir where is that
channel
where is that chin in ontario california
oh we can negotiate that
okay 51 51. 58. give him five grand down
right now that means we're financing 43
payments will be around 750 800 a month
they only they only do two doors for
this yeah that's what i wanted that's
all he needs oh
yeah because the whole weekend brendan
was i was back bro every time you got on
the phone
like man it's so wet we can't get it and
then what do we got to do
just just leave it in there just leave
that
man it's like consumed your entire trip
yeah well even when we were walking
through the the museum in my
he's on the phone yeah around 50 million
dollar card
around all these nice cars because he's
going hard
pedro was giving us like great facts
about these 50 million dollar cards
showing us all the engines because
they're like
exactly that area and i couldn't go
there i'm like well dad what they saying
about he was like bro now they're adding
another 300
because i left the key my my so total to
get it out
was 1200 because i took that's a
question that's including
dropping the key yeah no no that's
everything's included yeah and plus when
you when you had to go to fedex to pay
for that i had to pay for
it so all that 1200 1200
and i'm calling my bank right now we
sell this thing five grand you got five
grand down down five rand down there
on an m4 yeah that should be sick i
appreciate y'all
yeah so i gotta offer five thousand i
might just take it i would take that all
right well let's do it
well let's see here that's what happens
after episode and now we're getting a
bidding war
oh okay get that [ __ ] up 5500 maybe six
grand
i'm not doubting it i'll you buy the if
you buy it in the next couple of weeks
you get to keep
everything in the trunk what's inside
what's in the trunk a lot of [ __ ]
like what yeah
jerusalem slides
oh that's right and then let's let's go
and take out
uh a few hundo out of that five grand
because you need new luggage
yeah your knees my buddies walk through
the airport
the whole we got a shoe box it's a
grocery bag
i'm like what are you doing i'm like
dude you can you please get
i'm sorry i said hey dawg you go ahead
and not bring that luggage anymore
the new luggage it's on me we have to
leave
i was stressed out that day wednesday we
had to literally go to the airport i
think we're gonna drive by my parents
house
so i can drop this stuff off and then go
get my you know you know what's weird
you had the duffel bag in the shoe box
yeah why didn't you just put the shoe
box in the duffel bag
instead of just carrying the shoe like
you were tearing up empty shoe boxes
empty shoes through the airport with
this stuff why didn't you just put the
shoe box
so you're just chilling i hadn't there's
no room there was no room in the shoe
but uh am i definitely
like get out of here like there was
malik there was room no and i don't know
why you're carrying that shoe box around
yeah
i'm not selling gonna sell your shoes
why do you keep the box
anybody want some shoes i got these
cheeseburgers i brought the witherspoons
listen i don't know about
real shoe heads they know they well i i
don't like dusting around my shoes so i
like to put them back as soon as i wear
my shoes i put them right back in i
respect all that so again
that's why i had the shoe box and where
was the slides going to go my slides my
jerusalem
in the in the shitty duffel bag you have
from played against sports i had a lot
of
[Laughter]
but i had a lot of things that were
i had a lot of clothes in my duffel bag
believe it or not i had a lot don't
don't bring that same energy to austin
dude
i know especially you're wondering why
we didn't get looks
let's try to blame it
to the comedy club you still carry the
shoebox that's how you roll
it was the wooden spoons either way it
was a lot going on last week
sheila free i feel good thank you i got
something for your ass
oh you're doing something for your ass
hey they bullied me they clowned me the
whole time i couldn't even have a
comfortable flight because if jay
jay was like oh you need help oh yeah i
helped with your suitcases
your back's not bad though i mean no
one's even like jesus christ chappelle
my duffel bag from rooster fight you
love him but your bags
it's all dirty because it's a white bag
it's all frumpy
and it does some parts don't zip up so
it looks
like hey look i'll leave a bag in a
trunk if you just well we got
we got a hey we upgraded me okay yeah i
gotta share pal
yeah i'm working out as a jeep we gotta
upgrade you too you can't do
get too comfortable you're right hundred
thousand followers ten thousand
followers
not yet he's on podcast come on we got
it he got his own
i gotta cut wait shout out to couldn't
wait wake up
yeah no i got it i got it i appreciate
it i believe in you yeah yeah y'all
bullied me in the [ __ ] losing weight
yeah and you should wear you used to
wear vans dirty as hell
oh those came to already oh dude are
those ones you ordered
uh no these are the ones i ordered those
are awesome
it says love his title this dude named
uh
jake used to wear those bruce lee's
remember those yeah i still got the
bruce lee what are you talking about
bro they're fire fire they caught on
fire
it's a good thing right they caught on
fire please they still hold the [ __ ] up
again i'll be doing vampires i'd be
doing band pregnancy i got them
yeah those are those are house shoes man
no they're not they're not studios
let
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song